culture club getting back together after
all these years how does that feel to
you it's got to be obviously a lot of
people excited about it somewhat
emotional for you I would think there's
got to be baggage they're not now right
you know the minute you have to cut it
you can only deal with what's going on
now we've all grown up a lot
you know everybody's kind of everybody
really wants to do it yeah
but they think about bands it's you know
bands are like you know that's saying
you know you can't choose your family
you can choose your friends or the
band's like a family you don't choose
mm-hmm they happen they sort of become
part of your life and there's just no
getting rid of them right that's the
sweetest thing you've ever said to them
I love those fools you know what I
remember very clearly when Culture Club
hit in the United States and you guys
were such a sensation and the music was
great but there was also this style this
sense of style that you had that seemed
to come completely out of left field and
still have yes
people talk about as much as anything
else yeah I was gonna look back and
you've kept it up over the years you
keep transforming your snow we go back
to the classic there's the classic Boy
George book gifting mid-80s then we move
on to this look right here
fantastic that was my gone with the wind
that was your that was your gun with the
wind Scarlett O'Hara face moving on tell
us about this phase here that was
actually I wore that in Japan to freak
the band out basically I just turned up
on stage a wedding dress right and they
they were literally like gobsmacked yeah
what are you doing I was like getting
married to the world and then I love
this is a solo look that you had yeah
what is going on here
everything everything all at once like
everything and the kitchen sink yes
let's get it all on yeah it's like you
act you like you stood under a chocolate
nozzle I was actually playing
accountably berry in a musical cool too
booth at Bradford awhile on Broadway so
that was really my usual look right I
have had the same style since I was
about 11 I have had the same exact
haircut the same just the same all what
would what would you tell me to do do
you think I should stick with the same
thing I don't have you're a creative
ability when it comes to a look I think
if you're having which is not very often
but you're having a bad hair day if you
know this I've got something here which
would be great on you yeah they brought
this out the commercial break and I
didn't know what it was are you saying
it for some reason first of all I've
never had a bad hair
but if I did have a bad hair day you're
saying this is what I would wear
look like a kid they just made the
sheriff of the town don't I
that's fantastic I have such a massive
is this your that's my okay because I am
way too I have a massive and Andy is
your head even bigger than mine I think
so you gotta try this on Andy its I have
it yeah yes please
let me cook it for you alright yeah oh
that's good let's see this slide is
fries and that blows right off yeah I
need hats that are made for bears yeah
oh very nice that's working for you jack
that cones it
with the coming camouflage I could get
one made for you wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]